well before your first really big movie
Ocean's eight you wrote a note to
yourself and I love I feel like we could
be friends from this note so it said uh
you said I'm nervous about doing
something I've never done before and I'm
scared I'm gonna let people down that
like what's it like to look back at that
now because I feel like there's a lot of
like
childhood trauma event oh yeah oh yeah
people pleaser like I feel like yeah for
sure like what is it like to look back
at that now then you've had so much
success already oh man I mean it was
really cool to look back on it actually
and sad it was it was sad because I I
was scared and I think that we often are
and I really didn't know what would
happen out of like randomly being cast
in a movie with like Sandra Bullock and
Kate Blanchett and Rihanna yeah no
pressure yeah right yeah
um and which is hysterical because
you're like so memorable from it you're
the one
and I love all those ladies but you're
the one I was like she's funny yeah and
they were also like that was before I
met them so like after I met them it was
like they were they were like so kind to
me and it felt like we were a family but
like I think that note was important
because you'll always be scared you know
you'll you'll never you'll never really
be ready
um and you see how you change you evolve
uh so it just it gives me hope for the
future I guess it's cool that you're
that person that will just you know be
persistent and just keep doing it though
even though you're scared a lot of
people like if I get nervous about
something I'm like I'm out never really
yeah like singing or anything so if I do
something else and I'm nervous I'm like
why would I do this again you just you
just yeah okay yeah I don't push through
I'm just like oh not my lab cool I'm
like cool I love
I love strong it's like a very brave
thing
[Music]
[Applause]
great night